PR is so boring I need some 99 drama
stat I don't think we're that dramatic
I've been gone one week Jake and Amy are
dating and they've killed a person I
figured out the best way to welcome
pimento to the nine nine stay out of his
way maybe buy him a drink not do
anything weird I'm making him a goat
stew huh
all right yeah now this turkmenistani
dish is traditionally made from an
animal that's been so overfed it can no
longer stand
that's a dream everything is authentic I
even ordered the pressure cooker from
Turkmenistan so you're on a terrorist
watch list now oh yeah Homeland
Security's been at my house yep now this
just needs to cook for another 11 hours
32 minutes and six
what the hell boy you almost killed me
I'm not going out in a stew making
accident clary's gonna die saving the
president or Jerry's Never Gonna Die
there's no way we can clean this up by
ourselves we're gonna need help
what are you saying you know what she's
saying man
oh no
it's not a secret meeting Jake
it's an intervention the tips have to go
what why take we're worried about you
and you look very stupid come on guys I
think they're kind of cool retro no
they're terrible Amy come on you're
taking the tips right no I feel like I'm
kissing Vanilla Ice there was a time you
would have jumped at that chance you
have to go all right you guys got me I
did it as a joke I kept them ironically
pretty funny right I'm just gonna head
out
yes
I'll admit it went too deep down there
in Florida at one point I think I forgot
where the tip of me ended and the base
of the tips began before we just chop
them off would anybody like to say some
final words no that was one word that
counts thank you Rosa okay I'm ready
sorry I'm late everyone but trust me
it's worth it me and Jake are chip buds
what no
[Applause]
you know what I do see it it's bad it
looks bad hey man you okay you look a
little chubby fine I'm fine
I think he's dead okay we have a few
more questions for you doctor doctor huh
it's funny when people call dentist
Doctor we are doctors we do four years
of medical school yeah it's called
dental school but we learned about the
entire body but if you had cancer you
can call it dentists you know it's
actually harder to get into dental
school than medical school because there
are fewer dental schools because most
people want to become actual doctors
that's ridiculous it's not like we're
College professors calling ourselves
doctors not the same thing my friend
sure it is when someone has a heart
attack on a plane do they yell out yo
does anybody here have an art history
PhD a PhD is a doctor red it's literally
describing a doctor maybe let's refocus
no the problem here is that medical
practitioners have co-opted the word
doctor okay Captain I know we live in a
world where anything can mean anything
and nobody even cares about
apparently that's a trigger for me yeah
apparently I'm 23
. I'm dying not one word if that is true
still working on that afternoon almond
I've been sucking on it so long it's
smooth it's like sea glass you do you
I'll get that boy games
oops butter feet sorry about that sorry
you bumbling son of a [ __ ] you just
ruined my life I hope you get hit by a
truck and a dog takes a dump on your
face ain't nothing to see here just a
little hypoglycemic rage move along I'm
so sorry Hitchcock that's not me I'm
never like that that's okay it's my
fault I shouldn't have bumped your
cashew
cashew it was an almond you idiot I hope
you drowned in a tub I hope you have an
aneurysm after aneurysm after aneurysm I
tried to suck it up and go back to work
I put on my uniform and got in my car
next thing I knew I was on a plane to
Mexico didn't even pack a bag I bought a
bundle of novelty shirts at a nearby
gift shop this one says what's up
beaches set of [ __ ] for human reasons
but you hate humor well I'm a joke now
so
it suits me okay everything okay with
Diaz yeah she fell asleep five minutes
after I locked her in and she hasn't
moved in the past 10 hours she talks in
her sleep I'm gonna rip your head off
I'm gonna rip your damn head off grandma
oh Terror bear what if she sleeps
forever
all right listen up what you're about to
see is highly disturbing but please no
comments this man is in pain so above
all else be kind
good morning boy
let's just get it out there Vivian broke
up with me last night I'm sorry chuckle
bunny
Charles wait yes
your food dehydrator
oh God
it's official wedding's off
and this is what I'm like now
life is a pit excuse me I don't
understand did you already have a matrix
get up at home for some reason no Gina I
bought this with the money I was going
to spend on our honeymoon to Cape
Canaveral I'm so sorry buddy don't be
I'm settling into the darkness nicely
I definitely get you now
what you got there boy eggs in a bag
nothing brings me joy anymore not even
food now I only eat for sustenance
I'll just go
prepared a little something you did when
I was a little girl playing cops and
robbers with my brothers
please continue or I could wait no
waiting just toasting I want you to
toast I want to eat toast give me some
toast
no signs of forced entry at the door but
the window was dimming you don't locks
on your windows way to blame the victim
sorry I'm not rich like you missed one
percent they cost eight dollars you have
a fur bedspread why do you have so many
Lycra body suits and why do you need
eight full drawers of underwear because
I'm civilized less talky talk more
solving salt we need an itemized list of
everything that was stolen I already
gave it to Captain Holt 160 dollars in
cash one TV one large painting of a
naked lady on a lion one set of Joseph
Gordon-Levitt nesting dolls wow homemade
and irreplaceable one music box that
plays she works hard for the money when
opened one knockoff designer clutch okay
just buy another knockoff no I can't
silly Sue because the label no longer
makes the original so the Sweatshop no
longer makes the knockoff
Can you estimate the value of everything
that was taken emotionally 700 million
dollars
Rosa are you stuck in there no I'm in
here by choice oh cause I hear some
banging noises as if someone was
struggling to open the door no that was
the pipes or is it the sound of you
learning how to ask for help you know
you can't spell independent without
dependent and you can't spell go [ __ ]
yourself without [ __ ] you
okay I know you need help and time is
tight but I see there's blue cake on the
floor and I know what that means
vis-a-vis the sex of the baby so before
we do anything I'm gonna need a minute
sorry for all the Weeping and the weird
snort noise I made at the end it's
genetic all right listen the case may
not be quite as urgent as once thought
um
I dug it up out of my desk so you'd have
something to do on weekends because you
seem so lonely you cited chatter from
the streets that Garibaldi had
resurfaced I did I did I did but said
chatter may have been fudged
so you lied to me
not a pity you pity me I wouldn't put it
that way I would I am offended I am
angry I am very tired so I'm gonna take
a nap but when I wake up oh
you are in for it
how dare you how dare me
[Music]
what uh nothing I'm gonna go over to
there now
Jake what's going on why is Amy's Hair
like that oh she obsessively braids her
hair when she's nervous and she's super
nervous because she's taking the
Sergeant's exam today but Amy loves
tests not this one it's always been her
plan to be the youngest captain in the
history of the NYPD but if she doesn't
pass this exam she's gonna have to wait
another three years to take it again and
that'll disrupt her entire life calendar
is that a real thing it hangs over our
bed such a stress breeding big deal it's
like a one on the Santiago Panic scale
yeah but we've also jumped up to level
two creepily singing songs from The
Great American Songbook
a Grand Old Flag you're right
so yeah it's a little tough right now
but I think the worst is behind us why
are you taking
it
she'll be okay